yes my name is Lawrence mushroom the
Minister for Home Affairs for the United
Republic of Tanzania my belief is that
the world cup in 2010 coming to South
Africa can benefit not just South Africa
but Africa as a whole it really depends
on how we as other countries within the
continent prepare ourselves for this
particular event coming and be in
Tanzania I'm happy to say i have
prepared ourselves well we are making
sure that we will be advertising our
country in conjunction with in 2010
world cup and i would just like to give
this opportunity to welcome all those
who are listening to me now to visit
Tanzania see the resources at wolcott we
have in terms of tourism tanzania is a
beautiful world cup destination in
addition to that in addition to South
Africa